good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1864
[Music]
Keter special containment procedures if
a manifestation of scp-1867 outpost are
to reroute traffic away from the
affected area and prevent civilian
interaction with scp-1867 must be
deployed with this specific task of
locating and preventing access to
scp-1867 be instances cannot be
destroyed with brute force diplomatic
means of preventing civilian abductions
should be undertaken if at all possible
foundation misinformation agents
positioned in local news sources and
weather monitoring sites are toobut
tribute scp-1867 and large quantities of
dust present in storm water civilians
who enter scp-1865 attributed to common
inclement weather accidents
description scp-1863 logical phenomenon
characterized by heavy precipitation and
fog composed of cell water
human blood and human cerebrospinal
fluid as CP 1861 manifestations are
unpredictable appearing spontaneously
and with no regard to an affected areas
natural climate and weather patterns
manifestations typically occur once
every three to six months and have been
recorded occurring in numerous regions
across the world historical records have
confirmed that as CP 1861 has existed
since as early as the Year 1916 the size
of the area covered by a CP 1861 varies
from instance to instance with the
largest recorded affected area measuring
approximately 5,000 kilometres square
aside from its manifestation composition
an apparent connection to scp-1863-b
1861 displays no additional Xtranormal
properties scp-1863-b soul that closely
resembles b-class boats used by the
British Royal Navy in World War one
during H scp-1865 stationed scp-1867
ufff to contain its full mast both
natural and man-made bodies of water
have hosted manifestations of scp-1863-a
feci P 1861 a is present as CP 1861 a
will surface in any collection of water
with a surface area large enough to
encompass its conning tower and topmost
platform even if the collection of water
aquestion is only several inches deep
SCP 1861 be our humanoid entities that
emerge from a CP 1861 a during an SCP
1861 phenomenon scp-1863 suits
resembling deep-sea diving gear although
with no discernible source of air supply
instances of a CP 1861 B are uniform in
size and possess speed and strength
typical of an adult human male
although most instances are sapien tank
capable of speech approximately 9%
possessed limited intelligence and are
only sent in instances that are capable
of verbal communication have been
recorded making vocalizations similar to
the cries of domestic felines canines
and infant humans the diving gear worn
by a CP 1861 be instances is anomalously
durable and cannot be removed except by
the instance presently wearing it if an
instance of scp-1863-a into entering a
CP 1861 a claiming that this action will
be in the subjects best interest
subjects who refuse may or may not be
forcefully taken to scp-1863 ment of the
SCP 1861 be instance human subjects
lured into entering scp-1863 emerge
during subsequent scp-1865 stations as
scp-1867 be instance is taken outside
SCP 1861 s area of effect it will begin
to experience accelerated fatigue and
lose consciousness becoming completely
inert until reintroduced into scp-1865
station of scp-1863-a teen 61a will
disappear along with any remaining
instances of scp-1863-a cerebrospinal
fluid and salt water left behind by a CP
1861 will instantly convert into regular
rain water
interview log do see 1861 one
interviewed an instance of scp-1863-a
interviewer D 1861 36 receiving
questions from dr. clutch via remote
broadcast forward D 1861 36 was sent
into an SCP 1861 affected area and
instructed to interview in scp-1867 can
be heard throughout the interview and
scp-1863-b
[Music]
[Laughter]
and this is interview long do see 1861 -
interviewed an instance of scp-1863-a
1861 46 interviewer D 1861 45 receiving
questions from dr. clutch via remote
broadcast forward D 1861 45 and D 1861
46 adult males of roughly 30 years of
age had both been sent into a previous
manifestation of scp-1863-a time D 1861
45 was instructed to avoid contact with
scp-1863-a teen 61 46 was instructed to
enter a CP 1861 a heavy rain can be
heard throughout the interview and as CP
1861 be speech is muffled by the diving
gear it is wearing playing log now I
don't wanna know you're really sad
[Music]
proves you got his memories at least so
what happened after you went inside the
sub the inside of the sub is pretty much
just a narrow passageway the thing was
full of those diving suit along with the
budget a random folks from around the
time it was jam-packed in there you
could barely move he kept getting pushed
further and further back as more people
out there I got the more certain I was
that I hit a wall at the end but it was
like that passageway just stretch it
over forever
about an hour after I first that two
people stopped coming in and the hatch
was closed then without any warning the
sub started filling up with water what
they tried to drown me no man the water
just kept rising higher and higher
and what was screaming and panicking and
knocking each other over the guys in the
diving suits tried to keep everyone calm
explaining it was part of the safety
procedures there gave out diving suits
to the rest of us in ordered us to put
them on so their kids and bats were
cramming them into the suits just to
keep them from drowning to death makes
sense so I guess you were all trapped
down there for a whole nother six months
until the next blood range they have
actually we didn't have to wait very
long at all that's when things started
once everyone had the diving suits on
they opened the airlock and started
letting people sobbing but yeah we were
told not to take the suit off yet though
they told us that when we got out of
this suit I stepped out onto the surface
everything looked almost exactly like to
add an hour ago I saw the wake trees the
board houses everything was worried it'd
been what had something changed it's
hard to explain I want to say that it
was like everything around us was part
of the water itself when you looked up
you didn't see a surface it just went on
forever
then the trees the boat houses that
would solve it they were just a
different sort of liquid even when you
stood on the ground it was like you've a
swim into that because the ground was
liquid except you didn't actually have
to swim and even though everything was
water you couldn't still tell there was
a link there as if the lake was a sure
form of liquid miss sorry yeah making
any sense at all here no no uh-uh dr.
clutch wants to know how long you guys
are out there like that
all six months we lived like that day
and night did anyone try taking their
suits off
of course especially at first since
everyone was confused it's good as soon
as someone took their helmet off their
bodies sort of I think is all the best
word for it
they weren't solid anymore that kind of
turned into a mist and the water that
was all around us they lost their shape
still tell they were there shapeless
soon floating how did you guys ate
they're dead didn't sleep bad we just
breathe time that's the time by
exploring talking to each other did you
see any animals or other people kinda
see their bodies that's like three or
four feet off the ground and their hair
and fur would move like it does when
it's underwater but they always kept
their position and drift away or
anything like that it's really really
weird and all the dead six humans and
animals were missing their eyes blood
will just keep pumping nonstop from
their sockets and dissipated and their
teeth I can't just see their teeth were
gone because it doesn't begin to cover
it was like someone took a bite out of
their face right with her mouth should
have been teeth lips gums all gone
and no explanation from anyone what did
the guys who had led you into the sub
have to say about all this a lot of them
said they had the same story we did the
blood rain came then someone in a suit
told him to climb into the sub and then
BAM Waterworld was this one guy though
he said he was the original captain of
the sub Hershel Guthrie of the HMS
winter Schieffer was that he introduced
himself anyway the guy was he ever spoke
coherently if you asked him about the
sub we call it his arc
she asked him about the water place he
called it the New World
What did he say about people with
missing eyes and teeth he just said the
watcher of the eyes and biter of the
teeth deemed them more than crazy talk
like that had to wind up back in the
real world
was pretty sudden actually one day a
bunch of guys started yelling for
everyone to make their way back to the
southerner said that another area was
getting attacked and the rescue as many
people as possible all right
weird water to mesh mangled floating
corpses infinite submarine not all that
dr. clutch great but now why haven't you
taken off that suit already so so I'm
scared man I don't know what's real
anymore
that's really alive these diving suits
[Laughter]
[Music]
anymore
dr. clutch says you're gonna have to
take off the suit for science Molly I'm
just so scared if I'm not healing what I
learned is I think this helmet off what
I see before when we were in that storm
together the guys in the suits told us
that we die as soon as the rain stops
you know what during the time I spent in
that water place I found you teeth
missing eyes gone I saw your dead body I
don't know what's real man well what
else you gonna do get back into the sub
and live in SeaWorld the rest of your
life
who knows maybe it's not too late to get
back to normal if I were you I think
death will be better than whatever kind
of hell you're stuck in just take off
the suit already okay
closing statement SCP 1861 be removed
its helmet and large amounts of sea
water began to pour from the suit now
body was found inside but to human eyes
and a set of teeth were recovered within
the diving suit testing performed on the
remains revealed that the eyes
originally belonged to an eight year old
female and the teeth to a European red
deer cervus alavés and this is why
without foundation instructions I don't
go anywhere near the ocean and neither
should you thank you all for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
go away okay I'm sorry you were all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John reporter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal Judi
Dench cheese whip depths McGee and
oblong douche boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash live
organ thank you
[Music]
you